he has just announced the Amazon phone
we are getting word from inside the
event so Brad Brad stone here author of
the everything store book about Amazon
it is official yep they brought huge
surprise now by the way what I love
about that graphic very Amazon like
there are no actual numbers on the x or
y axis we got the number of graphic they
should am such a patent back but but but
the point is a good one prime is doing
hugely well and Prime members are loyal
they buy about twice the amount of non
primaries this I think why we're gonna
see this phone integrated very tightly
with amazon prime Gorilla Glass 3 with a
rubber frame Brad how much I mean this
David working on this since 2009 how
much thought has gone into all of the
smallest of details well you know as we
talked about yesterday that Jeff
distributed a book called mr. pines
purple house which talks about being the
one purple house on a block full of
white houses it took a long time because
they were on this journey for something
that would differentiate the Amazon
phone that would make it stand apart you
know features like Gorilla Glass that's
standard the Qualcomm chip standard 4.7
inch screen perfect size for one-handed
use yeah they're very standard but
what's different is going to be that 3d
display that we talked about Cory now we
know some of the details 4.7 inch screen
it is official a phone is room is
revealed you know what's your take on
the initial details you know they're
calling the fire phone I i would have
liked some Amazon like humor they should
have at least spelled fire with a pH but
no such luck you know fundamentally I
think I think we're gonna still wait and
hear we hear about pricing and what that
means and the way that Amazon's shopping
service is integrated into the phone and
what that user interface might look like
different primary users you know the old
line the Richard are different than us
they have money well prime users are
different than regular users they might
have a different use case and so the
phone shopping experience for the prime
user could be very different if they
chose to make that available to use as
in design around that that function
or that that different demographic if
you will we'll see what they tell us
about that user experience and pricing I
think it's going to be a key
announcement here prime certainly seems
to be integral to the experience I want
to bring in our senior West Coast
correspondent John Ehrlichman you've
been digging into how important prime is
to Amazon's business John just how
important is it well Jeff Bezos spent
some time initially talking about as
they rolled out more video people can
you know obviously lot watch a lot of
film and TV through prime that that's
one of the reasons why prime was more
adopted more people signing up for it so
the quarries point on pricing you know
having that to offer and whether or not
a carrier plays a role in you know
subsidizing the data that goes into
actually watching film and TV on your
phones I think it's a really important
point 13 megapixel rear camera on the
back Brad the details coming out what
are you thinking on price no we don't
know but you know the the the benchmarks
are you know the iphone 4s subsidized
$200 so you know they've got to do a lot
of work to make that phone competitive